We are now learning about the existence of
a literal, not proverbial pandemic playbook
that Donald Trump and the White House had
in their possession.
They'd had it for years and they just ignored
it as they continued to insist Corona virus
is no big deal and now everything's just fine.
This is a color coded 69 page long playbook.
It's a manual for fighting pandemics.
If they simply followed it, they didn't have
to come up with anything new.
They didn't have to.
The information was all right there.
They simply followed the 69 page document
that they had all along that they were briefed
on in twenty seventeen by the outgoing Obama
administration.
Think about how much better off we would all
be right now.
Think about how many fewer deaths we would
be on target to have.
The playbook dates to 2016 and the playbook
was created because in 2014/15 we had Ebola.
Lessons were learned.
So a playbook was put together.
This is called iteration.
It's called learning.
The playbook was made in 2016.
It was turned over to the Trump administration
in 2017.
They were briefed on the playbook in 2017.
Then, of course, Donald Trump disbanded the
pandemic response team.
We know where we are today as a result of
that.
And as you all probably realize by now, pandemics
are an issue of national security.
This is a national security document.
It's the National Security Council's pandemic
playbook, 69 pages.
And it was just ignored, simply ignored, like
it doesn't exist.
And this is another interesting thing.
On Monday, I gave a list of what should Trump
have done and when should he have done it?
Now, at the time, I wasn't aware of this playbook,
but many of the things I mentioned, including
the timelines, are literally in this playbook
right at the start.
So one of the things I said was months ago,
that's when the government needs to start
obtaining, securing and distributing personal
protective equipment, including masks and
gloves and looking at getting the ventilators
to where they need to be.
The playbook says one of the things you do
at the first sign of the pandemic is you ask,
is there sufficient PPE, personal protective
equipment for health care workers who are
providing medical care?
If the answer is no.
Should the strategic national stockpile be
released to states? Trump started talking
about this eight days ago, nine days ago.
Maybe the playbook says, just like I said
on Monday, that should have been done in January
at the absolute latest.
Trump simply didn't do it.
It was in the playbook.
It was in the document that they were given
the funding stuff, the checks and and the
stimulus.
I said on Monday, you need to start negotiating
and planning the bailout early so that the
money can actually get to people when they
need it.
We are now almost in April.
With luck, people will get their twelve hundred
dollar checks in three weeks and that's only
half because remember, you'll get a direct
deposit in roughly three weeks, assuming it
passes the House later today.
If you file taxes in 2018 or 2019, filed your
2018 or 2019 taxes and receive the refund
via direct deposit, that's how you'll get
your check, your twelve hundred bucks in three
weeks.
The other half is unlikely to get their twelve
hundred bucks for an additional three to five
weeks beyond that.
The playbook says plan in advance with legislators
to have the money ready.
They didn't do it.
It's actually shocking that the advice is
so obvious that even I who know nothing about
this stuff.
I was able to put together a list of stuff
that should have been done that we now know
mirrors much of what was in this pandemic
response playbook.
And they had the playbook.
They didn't have to do the thinking part.
They just had to do the doing part.
And they didn't do it.
They had a physical playbook with instructions
and they ignored all of it.
And what we now I mean, illicit data, there's
always these questions if you don't start
assigning blame in the middle of stuff, but
at the same time, if you think you need someone
else leading the cause, you do have to assign
blame.
When this is all said and done, is anybody
going to be held accountable?
And what I mean by that is when the death
toll stops and when we get beyond this, which
hopefully will be as soon as humanly possible,
are there going to be consequences or is Trump
going to get himself another four years?
Because as we've talked about yesterday and
earlier in the week, the approval rating for
Trump is up.
The portion of the population satisfied with
his handling of this is up.
And what I've really come to realize during
this Corona virus pandemic is I really prefer
my dystopias to be only in the fiction books
that I'm reading and not in reality.
I love dystopian science fiction, and yet
I'm finding myself struggling to read any
of it right now because it's all feeling just
a little bit too real.